[Laughter]
yeah my my daughter will be locked up
until she's at least 25 so you know and
so a lot happened before you got to that
moment and if you weren't willing to
address it
that's a lot okay so the whole point of
cheating
hey welcome you're watching led live
it's the show where we use the light of
christ to expose the darkness found in
media and our culture today we took to
social media asking you what questions
you may have about singleness dating and
marriage and we're here to answer them
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
hey guys um my name is michael and i'm
single hey my name is mikey and i'm
married
so my name is brittany and i am single
my name is deborah and i have been
married almost 25 years in april it will
be hey i'm brad i'm i'm married and uh
i'm happily married
hello my name is alex and i'm mary and
i'm very happy mary i'm keith i'm
married
i'm scottie i'm happily married
hey my name is candy and i'm single
i'm florence i'm kendy's mom and i'm
second time single
how's going brad good we got hearts
behind us i know
all right so uh i guess we're supposed
to answer these questions
all right why does it seem like god
takes forever to find a mate for us hmm
this is a good question
i think there's a lot of variables there
that you have to consider and trust in
god and sometimes he's building that
trust like do you really trust me
i think people would naturally treat god
as a genie if it was just like hey i
asked you uh where's my stuff at you
know where's my girl at where's this at
god has much bigger plans for you and he
cares more about your salvation and your
your character and your personality than
he does about you just having the
desires of your heart yeah that's why
the bible says seek and you shall find
me right and i will give you the desires
of my of your heart but the first part
of that really is a seeking after god
and
and then god will honor you what you ask
when we pray
thy will be done
it's god's will you got to believe it
he knows he knows when we are
emotionally ready when we are physically
ready when we are spiritually ready when
we are mentally ready
and so a lot of times he doesn't give us
what we want because we haven't done the
background preparation
and we're really not ready and if he
gives us what we want we're just going
to mess up and then we're going to blame
him
because that's what usually happens
people always blame god for all the
things that go wrong in their lives
joseph ended up being thrown he was you
know had these dreams that he was going
to be the prince of egypt and he was
thrown in a pit and
put in jail for something he didn't do
but in the end that's exactly where god
was leading him like nobody wants to be
in the pit nobody wants to be in jail
when you're not when you're innocent
and yet if he wouldn't have went through
those things how would he have ever
ended up where he ended up where
he was able to save many nations from
starvation good things come to those who
wait and who trust god i believe that
we're just we're we're very impatient
people that's why we have things like
amazon prime yeah no no can't wait
that's right that's right yeah no yeah
it didn't show up on my doorstep come on
assess yourself and see okay
do i like living with me if i was
somebody else would i enjoy living with
me
this this this is the time to make those
kinds of changes and like paul paul said
he has
come to the point where in every
situation every state he finds himself
he has learned to be content
yeah and so if this is your
season of singleness i say
enjoy it
all right
is it possible for a couple to get
spiritually attacked while having god at
the center of their relationship
100 yes yes
when you become a christian look satan's
not out there attacking the world he's
already got them
he you know he's
going after the christians it says in in
revelation it says
that the dragon was wroth with the woman
this is all symbolic the dragon is satan
the woman is the church the body of
believers he's going after those who
keep the commandments of god and have
the faith and testimony of jesus christ
so when you become a christian prepare
to have a target on your head because
you're enemy number one in satan's eyes
right when you're drinking and
partying and having fun with your
friends he's just
he's not going to mess with you imagine
if if he spiritually attacked one of
those people they'd be like well i
didn't believe in god but now i do and
lord help me he's only going to push
people to god
but when you become a christian and a
believer
be prepared for battle it's a very
dangerous
idea to think oh i'm a christian i can't
be a tech just because you are
in the boat with jesus doesn't mean that
there's not going to be a storm
you know
um i think that you should always be on
your guard and yes the devil's main
motive is divide and conquer he's going
to attempt to come into your home divide
and conquer and spiritually attack
doesn't mean
you're overcome oh yeah of course trials
they come and remember trials is
opportunity to develop character yeah
was was job ever a
i mean he was spiritual he was he's very
close to god but he was attacked too so
just because you you're doing everything
right and you're you're you're close to
god and you've uh had a successful
relationship marriage doesn't mean
you're not going to get attacked
i think though that one factor too is
you are going to be attacked and not
just in your marriage but in your
finances and with your kids and with
this and that i think that one of the
powerful things that gets attacked is
unity because unity is huge if it's just
squabbling over money and who left your
shoes out if he can keep you in
dissension
it doesn't matter how petty it is you
never arrive at that place of spiritual
unity so the antidote though is when the
attack comes to get in unity and to
stand against the attack together right
should a guy wait until he can provide
financially before courting oh that's a
great question i think you have an
answer for that oh i just that's a great
question
yes
um
right now in china
like
it's like
if you want to get married to a woman
most likely i'm not talking about 100
but most likely over 50
women
are looking for first you you can afford
a house you have to have a house
basically
and a car
a car a house
without those without those don't even
talk don't even talk to about marriage
you know when i when my wife and i were
getting married her goal was to have her
car paid off i had saved up some money
she had saved up some money but it's not
like we were financially independent we
were just debt-free didn't know on
school didn't know in our cars didn't
know anybody anything so it allowed us
to do is get some furniture and a few
things like that when we got married but
if we'd waited until it was like okay i
have this awesome job where i make so
much a year
that'd have been forever coming in fact
she had a better job when we got married
than i did
the reason that's a tricky question and
it's a bit loaded because you can make
less money
as long as you're out of debt you can be
doing better than people who are making
more money and are in debt right
the whole point of courting or dating is
to be married and if you can't support
yourself
in marriage
why in the world are you are you
preparing for this honestly i think
dating is expensive and
it costs money to go out to do things um
probably
i don't know
when you're building a house the first
thing you put in is
the foundation
and based on the strength of the
foundation
that house will stand or fall
when storms come
now similarly the foundation that goes
into a relationship
determines the strength of the
relationship
so if you have a strong foundation
financially
emotionally spiritually and all the
other areas
then your house your relationship
will stand somewhere i read this that's
the statistic saying that the number one
reason
marriages break up is because of money
finances that's true but from a biblical
perspective when we go back to the ideal
god's ideal found in the garden of eden
in genesis
god gave adam a home
the garden of eden he gave him a job to
dress and keep
the the garden and all of that was set
in place before eve was put into the
picture
adam had his purpose he had a way to
provide for his family and then his
family was given to him not necessarily
because of my age of course i don't
expect the person to have their dream
job or be able to
provide for an entire family but
they should be able to be in a good
place at least to keep themselves before
we before we get started and i have the
same
standard for myself i think that i
should be able to be independent and be
able to stand on my own two feet and
have my own personal connection with
christ and know about myself before i
join with with anyone yeah and when we
read the bible and we
see what god says about the husband
the husband should be a provider for his
family the man has to imagine that the
the lady who he's going to be proposing
to will be his wife
is not in a position to hold down a job
because in any situation something could
go wrong and then you have to be the
full provider in any case he should be
the full provider
if you find a lady who has a job and is
bringing that's gravy okay
you know i love it the man is supposed
to be the provider that's his god-given
role
right and so if you are not yet prepared
to be that
in totality
go and find a way to become the person
who can fully provide for family before
you propose to anybody to join you your
life okay yes i think he needs to be
financially stable now if there's things
that he's working towards
i think that's fine because we're not
married yeah you know like if you're in
college or pursuing something right but
if he's just content just like playing
video games at mama's house oh my gosh
[Laughter]
that's another episode isn't it
yeah but if he's like if he's working
towards something i think
yeah that's fine is having relations on
the sabbath right or wrong
for married couples
relations i'm not
audience or question here so we won't
get graphic this was a nice way of
putting that but having relations being
intimate with your spouse on the sabbath
what do you feel what do you think about
that
i love the sabbath yeah
that's a great day
[Laughter]
y'all crack me up
well i don't have an answer for this one
whatever the bible is silent on
i don't take it upon myself to play god
and tell people what is right or wrong
okay read the bible
pray and ask god what your question is
and let the holy spirit direct you
that's good
without being graphic um i think the
illustration that god has given us in in
to consummate a marriage right
um
there's an illustration like the jewish
sanctuary i mean you are the priest of
the household in that same sense as the
priest was to the to the um
to the jewish sanctuary system
and the only person that was allowed in
that most holy place was the priest you
are the priest of your household and you
should be the only person that's allowed
in that space and so i don't think god
would be like um you know i gave you all
these illustrations to understand these
deeper spiritual things but you can't
you know enjoy that now i'm going to say
that preference that with i think that
if that's your only focus in that day
your the day is really supposed to be
spent with god and if that's really what
your whole mind and singular focus is
all about then yeah that that might not
be a good idea but um
i personally don't have a problem with
it yeah me either
in the in the creation story god created
for six days
and then he rested on the sabbath but
man was created on day six
man and woman
what was the first command he gave adam
and eve
he said be fruitful and multiply
that's the first commandment he gave
adam and eve on day six so i mean
i don't imagine the next day they were
like oh we got to stop that
it's the sabbath
i think it's a gift from god and and
why would a gift from god be condemned
on the sabbath it actually says
in the marriage the bed is undefiled
i think that
um i don't think it has anything to do
with a sabbath and then there's
definitely no spiritual
guidance on stuff like that i think that
god made sexuality to procreate and to
enjoy and i think we're depicting some
intimate connection with him when we are
intimate and so i think why would he be
put off by that on the sabbath because
it's it's a portrayal like i say of
christ in the church it's depicting a an
intimacy with christ he designed it why
would that be taboo
on a certain day so so the principle of
the sabbath is to spend time with god
but
but i don't believe that you can't spend
time in that way and manner with your
wife
on the sabbath either the where i think
it becomes dangerous
and this might be
not for everybody but
having relations with your spouse on
sabbath
can tend to make you sleepy as well and
so you might miss the sabbath completely
and
if you if you miss that sabbath blessing
you can't miss a sabbath blessing every
sabbath even though that might be the
time when you get to spend the most time
with your wife or husband i don't know
well i'll let you answer it because i
asked about the pastor so
i'm gonna answer back
just this is good it's like this is
bonding
yeah
okay so
when marrying
is legally through the court sufficient
so if i was like hey ma like i just want
to go to the justice of the peace and
[Music]
done deal well you know what i would do
i i i've heard this question asked a few
times and what i what i think is the
better question is
if you want to marry someone why
wouldn't you want to tell the world if
you love someone so much why wouldn't
you want to only have a court marriage
but also have a marriage ceremony with
everyone else in it so that you can you
can share your love for the other person
i think that people are very diverse and
i think that what
some people having a big wedding would
give them a nervous breakdown they would
loathe every second of it and weddings
tend to bring out the devil and a lot of
people in the wedding party i don't know
what that is but
but i think that
the reason we have a legal ceremony with
documentation all that is because you
know adam and eve were not married in
the way that we are married
they never had any ceremony or witnesses
or anything except god there was no
certificate of marriage for them
but
the legal ramification came along
because i think it was god's protection
on women actually
because if a man just didn't like his
wife and want to get rid of her he could
just send her out homeless and with
nothing and he could just take another
woman but when there's that legally
binding
contract by recognized by the court and
by god
now there's accountability i think the
court recognizes the marriage for um
for reasons of of keeping order in the
country and things like that right and i
think that you don't necessarily have to
get married in a church but then i think
the flip side of that coin is you don't
have to get married in a courthouse or
anything like this to really in god's
eyes be married
sure i would think
if you go to the church and stand before
your family and a pastor and make a
promise to god that i i will forever
stay with this person through sickness
and in health till death do us part
that's more
official than a government hey what
about i'm not saying you shouldn't but
what about there's no church
i i've heard it put that going to the
courts like giving caesar what's to
caesar and then when you do it in a
church it's giving god what is god
but i mean
god isn't in the church building he's
omnipresent so just thinking about the
time that we're living in and how things
have been shut down or you know what a
family is unable to come and gather
having a kind of ceremony even if it's
within the courts i think it's fine
you're still making that declaration
that commitment to that person in the
face of god maybe you can invite a
pastor there or loved ones there and
i think i think
i think it's fine
i think it's sufficient you can pray
i mean you can pray before it is binding
the state considers it binding if
something should happen to your spouse
they expect you
to
fill in and to take responsibility and
do whatever
that's necessary so it is binding yeah
marriage is not about the day in
celebration and we know that because so
many people were divorced that spent
thousands of dollars on their ceremonies
i think that it's a heart condition and
it's a an exchanging of a covenant and
it's an understanding of when this day
is over i have this lifetime commitment
with this person
so i think that all of the fanfare and
stuff is completely
individualized but i think that the
the certification in the court is what
makes it legal before god and man
so i definitely think that's sufficient
i just think that um you know the rest
of stuff is personal preference
and culture and a lot of things like
yeah what do you have to say about how
jesus said marriage isn't for everyone
well that kind of takes the pressure off
doesn't it
matthew 19 11 and 12. i mean it's jesus
if he said it's not for everyone it's
not
he knows what he's talking about
he made the first pair and married him
so
it's true
but he said unto them all men cannot
receive this saying save they to whom it
is given for where there are some
eunuchs which were so born from their
mother's womb there are some eunuchs
which were made units of men and there
be eunuchs which have made themselves
eunuchs for the kingdom of heaven's sake
he that is able to receive it let him
receive it what does it mean to be a
eunuch
a eunuch is
someone who
isn't married but
from my understanding a eunuch also
is someone who doesn't have
genitalia because i know in
in the courts
the men were made eunuchs so they
couldn't
procreate with the king's
wife or concubines
so the other the men who worked in the
court were made eunuchs it's sort of
like castrating someone okay okay
um like it took me a while to even
figure out if marriage is something that
i even want from my own life that is
something i'm still trying to figure out
because i feel like there's a really
especially in the church there's like a
toxic like you have to get married and
if you don't you're a failure of
culture in the church so
but jesus and paul unfortunately they
are men they're not women
um but they were fulfilled
without
um
being married you know like they were
pursuing their life's purpose it wasn't
like
it's mandatory for you to be married in
order to
live the life that god wants you to live
you know back then marriage was
very high on the temple everyone
everyone was expected to get married
every woman was expected to have
children and on top of that they were
expected to have a boy first
so it was a lot of pressure yeah so i
think when jesus came he really tried to
remove
some of the
weight
that was placed on traditional things
and i i believe that that was one of
them and they say jesus doesn't care
about women that's liberation right
there
i think that if i'm remembering the
context right and i may not be but i
know that jesus when the disciples were
talking about divorce and they were like
you know
moses said we could just write a thing
of divorce and and get rid of our woman
and jesus said
you know only in the case of adultery
and and all of that and then they were
like well who you know should get
married and he said it's not for
everybody i think he was really bringing
home
our casualness about marriage and our
lack of understanding that it's covenant
and it's sacrificial and he was just
putting it back to him like if you think
marriage is just a time to use a woman
and get rid of when you're done with it
it's probably not for you i mean he was
just making it very cut and dried of
what marriage is and is not
and i think some single people read
those verses and they get really nervous
like oh no god's called me to be a
eunuch
but i think that you know the eunuchs
that were forced to be that way by man
you know i know that in the days where
the king has had a hero and all of that
they would castrate the males that were
over the harems because they didn't want
them producing an offspring it wasn't
the kings and so i know that there are
certain you know
things and you're also talking about
when the bible is written a culture that
we might not even be living out of today
but some people
like like you said you know
they don't desire that because god has
put something else in their heart
and marriage is not a purpose it's a
partnership you know and sometimes being
married can hinder your purpose right if
you're called to go to china to missions
you marry somebody whose family is here
and their roots are here and they just
want a normal life and job you may never
fulfill your purpose and you may choose
that marriage over the fulfillment god
had for you i think having the holy
spirit guide you in that is very
important too because you could very
well
just be in this mindset you're just like
okay i need to get married and then you
get married with the wrong person and
then it takes a lot
to recover from yeah and just to get
your life back to heal
so yeah that's definitely something that
needs just like holy spirit guidance and
if that's something that god puts on
someone's heart i do believe that god
will fulfill that by bringing a person
right but i think there are some people
who know like
it's not really for me and that's
totally okay yeah
wow how can single people 35 plus years
old manage their expectations
i think that when you get older you get
more set in your ways at least i i am
now i feel like you know i'm i'm into my
40s and i know what what i want i know
what i what i like what i don't like and
and you know i'm not as wishy-washy as i
was in my early twenties
um
and so i think some of the challenges of
that is to find somebody that that fits
into that
model of everything that you've gotten
used to
is a hard sell that's a hard person to
find when you're younger you're more
pliable you're more bendy um you guys
can grow together you haven't quite
figured out your finances yet you
haven't quite figured out some of these
like you know milestone things but but
when you start to get into the older
ages um um i think your your your focus
is becoming more narrow and it's hard
it's going to be harder for you to make
those adjustments not not saying it's
impossible just saying that it's harder
so um if you're 30 35 years old and you
really feel called to to um marriage you
know i would really i would really sit
down and say god is this is this in my
is this in your design for me and if it
is you know help me to really have an
open heart and an open mind to it and
and help me not to be so rigid with
the way that i've you know ordered my
life
i think that maybe discouragement can
come in and you think what's wrong with
me i'm this age and i'm still single and
so i think that
um
you know there's a lot of different
factors in
in relationships and not everybody
that's in a relationship is happy i
think that sometimes we can
discount singleness and think that
that's a mark against us or a sign of
inferior order or rejection and really
paul was thrilled to be single right i
mean he was like yo they're married
you're gonna have some trouble you know
and uh he had some trouble too he was
shipwrecked and beaten and those kind of
things but not by a spouse so
um
so i think that one expectation is that
everybody has to be in a relationship i
just think that's not true and some
people are very free to do things they'd
never be able to do if they were in a
relationship you got to start settling
at some point yeah that's why i'm saying
you know where it is you know
any woman
that's nice as a woman
no i see i see the question yeah yeah
just a joke be realistic yeah
that that's that's a that's a joke on
the
chinese internet they're saying yeah
and just
anybody as nice as a woman
you order just are you female all right
are you a female or single man no just
just kidding yeah
i think it's you have you still need
some expectations yeah still have to
find the right person don't
lower your expectation of finding a
spouse with the same beliefs stick with
that right but maybe not looking for the
supermodel right because realistically
that's superfish on us we're all gonna
start looking ugly and old anyway at
some point that's what my mother told me
oh okay she's like you you
yeah when you're getting older you you
can't just you know just go for like
good looking girls all that stuff we
like
yeah you want to think of
um how you spend the rest of life with
her she has to have a good quality good
advice
if you have the expectation you better
be prepared what do you mean
the first thing the person needs to do
is okay i am expecting to be married i
want to be married am i ready for
marriage uh i mean okay so you need to
take the time
and look at your personality your
temperament
and all of that do the self-assessment
yes
a lot of people age is not um
age does not determine maturity ah
that's true that's very true i've seen
some 60 year old people who never grew
up
and so you want to make sure
that at 35 or whatever age you are
beyond that
take time to reflect and assess yourself
am i really ready for marriage do i have
the personality the temperament to
accept someone else's view
over mine if we come into some type of
dispute and just look at the different
things that come with marriage am i
ready to give up my will
for
some other person or for a child who may
come
assess yourself so that's one you have
time to assess yourself
um and the other thing is
one way of managing your expectation is
to be open-minded and try new ways of
meeting people
you can't stay in your house all day and
expect that god's gonna drop some man in
your house right you're gonna be places
where there are people
and so you have to find yourself where
those people are
and now there there are quite a few
singles ministries
who have online programs they have
online socials and speed dating or
whatever they call them
but they're there look for them
what do you do when your partners when
your partner cheats on you because if
that happens to me i'm going to divorce
yeah
personally for me if my partner would
cheat on me i don't think there's a
going back because
you broke my trust i will never be able
to have peace and trust you again
you know so that's like a
that's a no-brainer for me
well it sounds like you've already made
up your mind marriage is so intimate and
so covenant and you're trusting your
entire
self to another person and it's very
vulnerable and very very personal and
for someone who probably already has
trust issues and it took them forever to
even arrive at that point with their
spouse
their trust towards them might be so
damaged this is a very very
case by case hard thing to to say
there's this hard and fast rule this is
the way you should do it and if this
happens to you this is how you'd react
i guess i'll frame it in the way that i
guess i would hope i would react
with
love and compassion and like let's get
to the bottom of why this happened and
and and try to resolve it
it's a heavy one
well i believe uh
you know god gave us the
the
the principle of forgiveness
when are you
the other persons come to you and say
you know what i really from my body my
heart and i'm sorry uh we can see also
a nice
forgiveness a nice
uh like i say you know like a principal
that you see that those
the couple they come together
and they say you know what now my
relationship with my spouse is stronger
than before
you know i keep going back to the
spiritual component of marriage right we
have committed adultery on god so many
so many times with so many different
things we've chased after other gods
we've made everything our idol and you
know god is so quick to forgive us and
ask for you know for us to come back and
return to him
and so i i think the first and foremost
thing i would do if i got into a
situation like that either found out my
wife was cheating or caught her cheating
or something like that um i would just i
mean it would drop me to my knees on a
on a on a probably
large scale throughout the day all the
time and and and i would just hopefully
i would latch onto god and just say
you've got to show me how to make it
through this because if it's left up to
me and i'm just going to react off my
emotions i would probably make that
decision as well like i don't want to be
at this person
i i don't think there's any fail
safe
thing to do that would 100 be like
fireproof insurance against that
happening in your marriage but i'll tell
you what one thing i believe that would
really significantly help your odds out
is if you had god as the third leg in
your marriage
the beautiful thing too about god is if
you look at the book of revelation the
way he describes his bride his church
is a pure woman yeah he doesn't even see
her
and
in in reality you know she's been
cleansed she's been restored she's been
renewed
and so
god is i think showing us a picture that
yes this is how the
the church or israel has treated me
but
i can
make that situation new again
you can be as as pure as if nothing ever
happened
[Music]
that's the like the hardest that would
be the hardest thing for me to to
overcome if if
i'm gonna really need to hope like get
it's either the lord changes
whatever this is inside of me or i'm
just gonna really need to find someone
who is compatible in a sense of being
really loyal being self-disciplined and
you know
wanting to get to the root of an issue
like if there's something that i'm doing
that makes you feel that you need to
step out or if there's something you're
struggling with or some like
relationship that's there and you
don't pause and try to figure it out or
come to me and let's work it out and it
gets to the point where
the action happens because people don't
just fall into cheating it's a process
and so a lot happened before you got to
that moment and if you weren't willing
to address it
that's a lot okay so the whole point of
cheating
from a man's perspective it doesn't have
to be anything wrong with his
relationship at home okay
because men just
love the conquest when you when you make
sure that you have the kind of
communication and you treat each other
as a king and a queen
this for ladies when you treat when you
treat a man the way that when you tell
him what to expect ahead of time
and then when you fall you come through
and you treat him in that way you show
him respect you you um make sure that
you
go with him you do the things that he
likes whatever it is you decide on
that you need to know how to hold this
person
in such a way that they will never think
of
another woman the way that they think
about you so that's one
but you're not
it's not impossible for you to be doing
everything necessary
and somebody still goes and cheats
because most men don't think i'm going
out there to cheat
they go and they get they find
themselves in some situation and because
they're very visual
one thing leads to another one thing
one thing leads to another for a lot of
men you listen to men talk
and they'll tell you they love their
wife deeply didn't mean to cheat
whatever happened
so
if you notice in the bible that's really
the only
thing that jesus specified the only
reason he gave for divorce
he specifically mentioned it now there
are the reasons that people get divorced
for that i believe god accepts however
he actually mentions that one
when you commit adultery or fornication
you're sitting against your own body and
that is why it's so hard for women to
take that because when women bond with
men they give a whole their whole self
over to this person
so when the man goes and bonds with
another woman in the same way you bring
it back into it
it's as though they
have
killed that woman that wife yeah okay so
that's the one reason god says you know
if that happens divorce the guy however
if you can find it in your heart to
work through it yeah
what i have found from people who've
gone through that the relationship
actually becomes stronger
thereafter wow i've heard that those
marriages can sometimes be even better
off down the road than they were in the
past
and and maybe sometimes it takes
something like that to stoke the fire
and break everything and then rebuild it
back up but
um i would seek counsel for god counsel
from you know maybe a spiritual mentor a
pastor or somebody like that family
members um and i would i would be very
cautious not to tell
a ton of people
and you know human nature how it is they
find out one person is cheating and then
all of a sudden it's like especially if
you're in a church setting the whole
church is going to turn on that person
what happens if you get back together
with them you know
so
now there are some men who will still go
and do it again because that's the
example they had
when they grew up with a father who was
a philanthropy
and that is why you need to know
people's backgrounds before you marry
them that's right because a lot of times
people do what they grew up with because
they think that's how things are done
and they may not think it on a conscious
level but it's in their subconscious and
your subconscious directs your behavior
most of the time
i also think that perspectives change as
you age
and as you experience life and as you
see life happen to other people more
grace so
it's it's up to you and god god knows
what you can bear and he doesn't hold it
against any woman who decides
i'm divorcing you because you are
unfaithful yeah there's a lot of people
that feel like you know that's the make
or break that's the
unpardonable sin of marriage you you
cheat on me it's over but i've i've
heard so many testimonies
um including eric wilson's on um
the dragon revealed if you watch that
story he actually divorced his wife they
were
christian married had two kids one was
in diapers and one day he just walks in
and says i want a divorce
his wife was just floored almost fainted
like just never saw it coming she's like
we're christian we don't get divorced
he signed the divorce papers she tried
to fight that but only could for so long
then
he was in his own apartment with
different girlfriends and she'd knock on
the door and his girlfriend would answer
and
and she'd be like i need to speak to my
husband and she'd say you don't have a
husband and she'd say yeah i do because
god doesn't believe in divorce and he'd
come to the door and he'd cuss her out
the top of his lungs and say get out of
my life you're ruining my life but she
clung to these promises she had
hand-written promises
about how what god
joins together no man can separate and
and it was really about his salvation
his walk with god because if he was
really walking with god
the way he should have he wouldn't have
even
done those things he wouldn't have
wanted to break a covenant with god with
his wife
he wouldn't have wanted to have
girlfriends living with him
and so
she prayed those for five years
and after five years
he called her up and he tells me he says
mikey if she would not have prayed those
promises i would never be back in this
marriage he said
i had no reason to come back he said i
hated her she was ruining my life but
she kept praying those promises and it's
called intercessory prayer it's when you
intercede for someone who's been blinded
by the enemy the bible talks about those
who have been
blinded their hearts their minds have
been blinded by the god of this world
and it's it's literally a spiritual
warfare that's
you've opened up the gate to allow the
enemy to have a foothold and he's
influencing you in a way
who are you
to say that that
sin is any worse than any sin that
you've been forgiven for
you know jesus said forgive
those who persecute you pray for those
who persecute you love your enemy even
this is spiritual warfare when
somebody has demons influencing their
life they're not even in control anymore
that's literally not them we wrestle not
against flesh and blood that that battle
is not against you and your spouse
that's against
the spiritual host of wickedness and the
only way you can fight that battle is on
your knees pray to god say lord go in
there and save my spouse
and intercede for them say lord they're
blinded lord forgive them for one to
break covenant forgive them for
infidelity and adultery lord forgive
them for the things they're doing in
their life
and
if you really truly loved your spouse
and made a covenant to god
then
no sin should stand in the way of that
because we we've all sinned we've all
we've all sinned and fallen short of the
glory of god and we can all be forgiven
we can all be transformed and change and
every past sin is washed away
even the sin of infidelity and adultery
so i think that um
even if you do not stay married that
doesn't mean that you have to be bitter
or resentful or
forever damaged by that person you can
have the marriage end and still forgive
that person and still allow god's love
to heal you and to show kindness towards
them but that's a very different thing
than staying in the relationship right
yeah
all right what is a good
way to maintain a healthy relationship
when it's long distance ha don't do it
that's exactly what i was gonna say oh
well i had the experience on that
because uh
did you meet her on the internet no it's
like
in china okay before i came here wow
so yeah we broke up but
yeah we broke up
long distance is hard yes especially
in my situation it's not only long
distance it's also like it's two
different countries
there's a time zone difference when mind
here is daytime it's my life oh wow what
did you what did you think
about that relationship where do you
think the future that could have gone
how would
how would you the perfect scenario for
that to have worked yeah like when get
to work when i when we
have work when we can afford
you know
when i can afford like take her come to
america
that's kind of my did she want to leave
china leave her family and all that
at that time yes
after i broke up no so when we are
fighting no yeah but yeah when you are
in love yes yeah i don't think it's out
of the scope of a of a you know a good
beginning just because it's long
distance i wouldn't avoid those right
off the bat but there are some
challenges that that will ensue it
because of that i do not encourage
long-distance relationships
at all
well they don't work
in my experience
i've not seen one that has worked well
same
i think
i think the most ideal when it comes to
long distance is for it to start with
you guys together
and then if something comes up maybe
they get a job or
it just happens that then it becomes
long distance that's better because at
least you had that time before at the
initial
phase of the relationship to really get
to know who this person is
seeing how precious time is i had a
really close friend she got into a
relationship with someone long distance
for like nine months and finally after
nine months they were able to
meet
um
so she went and she met with him and
first time she
got in the same space she was like oh no
this is not gonna work
and um you know the person was a great
texter a great person on the phone but
super awkward in person and he was a
great person but she knew that long term
that that wasn't really gonna work
because it was always that that was just
who he is he wasn't going to change
but nine months of your life is gone
you've created this tie this connection
with someone
and it just falls apart when now you're
meeting together and this is supposed to
be the rest of your life you're gonna be
together with this person for the rest
of your life if you decide to
to tie the knot with them so no
start i would say the other way around
start together make sure you're good
together and then separate then start
separated and then wait so you can come
together
i just don't like wasting my time and
the whole thing is dating and courtship
is getting to know the person
and getting to know the person under
varying circumstances so how do you do
that i mean one of the things that i
told you i learned as a teenager one of
my instructors he used to tell the
people who went to him for marriage
counseling
show up at show up at at your fiance's
house at six o'clock in the morning and
see how their face looks right
say something
deliberate because that you know it's
gonna make them really really angry and
watch their re response or reaction so
like you go out date right you know you
know they're gonna go to a restaurant
and see if they cuss out the waiter or
if they're polite
are those like details yeah yes it's one
thing to see their face some of us can
have a poker face that's right but your
body doesn't lie so when you're talking
to people you have to learn to read body
language
how do you do that long distance you
can't do that someone could tell you
yeah i'm great with money but then you
go shopping with them and they splurge
the whole paycheck you wouldn't have
known that unless you were with them go
out to eat how do they treat the waiter
how do they treat their family you
should see that not just hair it's good
to hear stories you should develop a
trust with that person but
seeing is evidence for sure actions
speak louder than words
definitely anyway
sorry if you're in a long distance and
you were really
looking to see how to make it healthy
but you know another way to answer this
fine if if that's just how it is because
there are people this does work for some
people they met online far away and they
come together and it works out and you
know they're happy for years to come
what i've heard is that the best thing
is communication
what's a good way to maintain a healthy
relationship
um i would say share that's
that's
one of the most important
you guys you two are not
together but you wanted to
make it feel like you together the way
to do it is to share
share what happened to you share
share your thoughts you know share
communication yeah communication like
even small things even little things you
miss something
you know you're happy you're sad you
want to share your emotions share your
thoughts share your stuff
just
pretend that they're together with you i
like that answer i think uh the main
point
if you're gonna have that kind of
relationship
uh is trust
you know put in the trust i mean it's
something like a peace of mind
you know when you love the person and
say you know i trust you
and
i believe the other person is going to
look at it
you know if that person
loves you
he's going to say wow i mean
you know 100 tries i was like wow i mean
that's so cool you know but it does
challenge you to
express love in different ways and i
think that's super important you know to
learn like what is it like if someone
likes quality time how are you going to
be creative to meet that need of theirs
to make them feel loved or if it's words
of affirmation that one's probably the
easiest one or gifts you know there are
different ways to express hey i really
like you i really care about you yeah
i'd say keep the communication high yeah
um it's just like it is with god you
know a good healthy relationship is in
communication and if you're not
communicating with god through reading
his word through prayer things like that
it's not gonna be a healthy relationship
anyway even if it's long distance or
close distance
so
you know i remember when when i was
interested in my wife
like on break and stuff winter break and
things like that
we'd get on instant messenger
you know remember those aim and
what was the one for uh msn messenger
and stuff like that it's probably
dating ourselves but
but icq and things like that or our
email you know we were in the habit of
communicating um that way
in the beginning and then as things got
more serious you know on the phone every
night
so travel back and forth like once a
month or something or twice a month just
to make sure that they see each other
bible reading plans together like
devotional together and stuff and just
kind of focus on their like building
their relationship with god together but
you know what i think that raises an
interesting point there's some
advantages to long-distance
relationships and i think that one of
them is
if you eliminate the physical which is
so distracting and can get you caught up
where you're so focused on
the attraction and the connection and
the physicality that you don't build the
time developing the stuff that's going
to sustain over the long haul and when
you remove that element where it's not
even possible you're forced to get to
know somebody's heart and to know
who they really are and all that without
the physical element and i think that
that's an advantage that that can be
really leveraged but i also think if
you're in a long-distance relationship
it begs the question
if we become serious and want to marry
how do we bridge the gap is one person
going to move and give up their life and
if so who and is that going to cause
animosity in the future and is somebody
going to feel like they always sacrifice
to be with the other and eventually
there is going to be a bitterness and i
think that you know
if somebody's in the military that's a
very different thing but if somebody
just has a job and a life established
elsewhere
that's a huge challenge and i think that
you kind of want to have that
conversation early on and have that kind
of stuff decided because you could be
wasting years of your time if you're not
ever going to make that connection and
get married and move
together you know if that's never going
to happen
you're just keeping each other company
you know and that's okay if that's what
everybody knows and expects
i think there's this motivation to do
everything you can to create the
foundations that you were saying before
so that you can go and see that person
or maybe build such a life where they
can come to you and you guys can prosper
together so that might be even more
stoked to hey let's get this process
going then if you could
it's easy to get kind of subtle or
stagnant when you're when you're in the
same place
but i think i think the whole online
dating thing and getting to know people
through
distant communication works better for
more mature people
i don't think that would work for
younger people actually more mature like
23 is mature no
sorry
i think beyond 35
you probably could handle that better
because by then your frontal lobe is
fully developed
your sense of reasoning and just
judgment
is a lot better it's in place
so you can
handle things in a different space
headspace
mentally than the one who's younger okay
what is the issue with dating or
marrying someone who is of a different
faith
oh great question because that's
like what happened to me
and
when i met my wife it was different um
denomination
so it is a big issue let me tell you
uh because let me tell you marriage is
not just a few years but it's for
eternity
and you need to find a really
uh you need to pray and fast
knowing that after
almost 21 years of marriage
and
faith is so important in our lives
and it's been it was very difficult the
first years of my marriage when faith is
so important to you it becomes one of
the big issues in your in your marriage
because because you want you and your
wife to be on the same page as each
other if you can't decide on on basic
things
that
faith
oftentimes is is you know
has some things that are that are hard
rules and some denominations some
churches some some
faiths don't really
abide by those and others do and so it
causes
tension oh yeah and you are as one with
someone else
so it's hard to hard for your marriage
to continue i think when you marry
you're not just marrying that person
you're marrying their family you are and
uh you know if you are in different
denominations which have some very
different lifestyles i mean some worship
on different days some have different
eating habits some have you know some a
wide variety of differences than than
even the same faith in christianity um
and that can be a rub
it's not biblical straight up don't be
unequally yoked and that takes different
forms being of a different faith is one
of them
having said that
there are situations where
a person you might have two people
they're atheist one of them becomes
christian they're already married
that doesn't mean you divorce the other
person
you know
um
it's i would say it's not wise given
what the bible says to seek out another
person who is not at least
christian
now
in the whole denominational scope there
are
varying
viewpoints i know there are people who
feel very strongly like you should only
marry
within your denomination
it's probably
ideal
i don't know that it's a guarantee that
it's going to work out
just like it's not a guarantee that it
won't work out the other way
there are
i think it's a
largely it's about odds right
you know odds are if you marry in your
denomination
you are
more than likely going to be on the same
page multiple levels and things are
going to be okay but it's not a
guarantee for success in your marriage
there's so many other variables
in my life my wife was not the same
denomination as i was when we got
married
so that was tricky on multiple levels
she was a christian i knew she was
christian she was committed christian
it's interesting i heard a preacher once
say that
abraham isaac and jacob
all
took their wives from the areas that we
know as babylon
it doesn't mean that they were
babylonian in their
in their lives or thinking
um because they were all
uh
godly women
right
but they happen to be in a different a
different geographical space
so the way i have a tendency to look at
that is there are people who are
searching and seeking and they love god
with all their heart
and they may not be in your denomination
but it doesn't mean that god isn't
leading and working on them along the
way
if you're a believer and you get with
somebody that's a non-believer
you think there's going to be conflict
in the house like
why can't they watch this spiritualism
on cartoons and be like because the
bible says bible okay you know i could
definitely see that be a lot of conflict
a lot of disagreements
how to raise your children what you
should and shouldn't do as a couple i
mean what if your spouse is like let's
go to the bar tonight and you're like oh
i can't do that and they're like why not
when children come that's one area of
a lot of contention
because
then the decision is okay whose church
should they go to
do they go to my church one week in your
church the next week
if one person believes in
in
sending their children to a christian
school of their faith and the other one
doesn't have that
and then public school is free and
public exactly so where's the child
going to go right so when children come
into the equation there is a lot of
conflict confused people don't do
anything
and so what happens to a lot of children
who grew up in homes where their parents
of different faith they don't have any
faith they become unchurched and for
many of my friends who
ended up marrying outside of their faith
that's when their marriage broke up when
they had children and the children
became a school age
then there was all this contention and
the investment all these years and now
you break up over that it's like oh i
can't imagine it's really sad yeah but
let me let me be upfront with you right
i've met some incredible guys
who aren't of my faith it's really
unfortunate
have i considered this absolutely
it's crazy though because sometimes you
find
like the strongest chemistry or
connection with people who are outside
of the faith but you know i had to
really tell myself um
i have to trust the process
i have to trust that god had a reason
for being so explicit about that
in the bible
and like lord man you better have
something good waiting for because
listen god knows best i think if god is
a very important part of your life and
you can't share that with someone it
will start to clash because i think
after all the butterfly feelings and all
that is gone you really are left with
you guys's values and if you can't
uphold that
it's
you're just not going to be happy yeah
like if you want so if prayer is a big
part of your life and you feel like the
person that you want to be with isn't
praying for you when you're going
through hard times
hard times and he's just like
you know i i've been in that situation
before and it's like it's just when
everything's all said and done it's just
not something that works out it is never
wise
to deliberately go against something god
expressly says in his word we should not
do right
but i mean we cannot expect him to bless
it because i have a friend who says to
me oh god always sends them so that i
can
um he sends the fish so i can
i can clean them up what oh i know i can
catch the fish so he can clean them up
and i'm like i don't know how you get
that
from the bible
because that's just
rationalization you know rationalization
because in my experience
many of the people who
marry outside of their faith or marry
someone who doesn't really have
any
christian faith they're more like
unchurched it's always the person who is
more spiritual
that waters down their faith to match
the other one
almost every time that's what i've seen
true there's oh someone has to be to
submit and someone has all things tend
towards equilibrium
right that's a law
of life
and usually it's the person who's more
spiritual
whose spirituality
goes down to match the other then the
question is what are you what are you
willing to give up you know and then
that kind of speaks to
your relationship with your god um i
read something
i was reading upon a relationship thing
and this lady says
the
your relationship the person you choose
to be in relationship with is a
reflection of your relationship with god
i thought that was profound
we could sit on that for a little bit
yeah
all right is intimate kissing while
dating okay for christians
well
it's like you know how close can we toe
the line how uh
how many times can i pet the bear before
he mauls me
you know i think um i think song of
solomon kind of puts it best he he says
you know what
don't let the love passions awaken
uh until it's time
and i think kissing brings out those
passions
and if if you awaken that during before
it's time then um you got to deal with
more than just hey is this the right
person you got to deal with ah you know
why aren't i with this person why why
can't i spend time with this person
right now and and maybe it might not
wake awaken the same
desires in the other person and then
you've got a conflict and it just causes
all kinds of havoc in your life
you know when you start
down that road of intimacy with somebody
the last thing you want to do is stop
you know so and it's so easy
to
cross the line you know it's it's you
know your your willpower is only so
strong
so you you know you have to know
yourself you have to know the other
individual
and
it's better to just
not go there
and because you don't want you don't
want any regrets
i think it also throws a a layer of
complication in there to where you
should be focused on do i actually
really enjoy this person not the
physical feelings i get when i'm being
intimate you know like like do i do i
really see myself as as enjoying because
beauty can fade youth can fade all those
things that that you think you're all
attracted to in the beginning
um and then you're left with the person
the real person for me i was thinking
about this because it's such a
challenging area when you're in a
relationship because there's all of your
desires don't just go on hold because
you're not married they're all there and
asserting their presence
but then when you start venturing there
it's really hard to
put boundaries or no you know because
chemistry doesn't care about all of our
faith beliefs i mean you know
uh
but
i i know that um
that there's a scripture that says it's
better for a man not to touch a woman
you know when you're not married and it
sounds so prude and so whatever but
here's the thing i think it's really
just a respect for biology
our bodies are made to respond to
certain things without conscious
volition there are certain things that
you do
or that's done to you that just evoke
a response from a different part of your
brain than you control consciously
there's all the intimacy without the
protection of the marriage and there's
all the insecurity and there's this soul
tied to this person that you're not in
that kind of connection with and so it's
a protection on you and your emotions
and and what marriage is intended to be
to not get into sexuality outside of
marriage because it can be so damaging
and it's so confusing
so i think as far as
um you know asking you know where the
boundaries and what you know is a peck
on the cheek or is he and all that i
think that it still goes back to being
led by the spirit
because people are so different and what
arouses them and what makes them you
know
feel a certain way is very different you
know one person touching them on the
shoulder might be like hey you know
another person they might have you know
a very low inclination and so they you
know holding hands or kissing whatever
is not really that you know uh
weighty to them and so i think that just
respecting sexuality is really the
valuable thing not a certain set
behavior but an awareness of until i'm
married to this person they're a brother
or sister in christ
they may eventually marry somebody else
who is a brother and sister in christ
also we may all go to the same church
together
as a brother and sister how do i treat
them with love and respect even if i
feel the attraction because right now
that's not part of the equation and they
could belong to someone else and how i
interact with them
is going to influence their future
marriage i wish i
learned that before
because in different cultures
you know they're i mean different how
they pushing you on the situation of
relationships and stuff like that
uh and the latino community
my culture i mean
one of you like early age 12 whatever
i mean it's like oh your girlfriend's
coming you know something like pushing
you you watch those soap operas you know
kissing and all the stuff all over the
place
um
but let me tell you
what i learned is
what is the last phrase
when the priest or a pastor
that had the ceremony
when people are married
what is the last phrase that they tell
him you may now kiss the bride so it is
an action or a question
it's it's an action it's an action so
let me tell you
now it's just like so that means before
that you couldn't oh
that's what i learned and i'm like
well let me i mean wow are you
interesting because let me tell you you
go to the pastor for what
for a blessing
[Music]
so if you don't want the blessing you
gonna go
las vegas and like
whoever is gonna bless you know get
married so you go over there to ask him
for a blessing and for the last check
this out
the last one hour ceremony
the seal
of the ceremony like it's over
and the jewish community i think they
break stuff you know
play to something or something like that
and of course they're kissing himself
but the last thing is is a kiss
[Music]
that they seal that ceremony like this
is okay now
and then after they kiss
the pastor says
now i present you
uh mrs and you know whatever the last
name and stuff like that so i learned
that and i'm like wow interesting then
you know okay
can this person respect
my wish
because if you
don't respect
one of my wishes
then it's very possible yeah you may not
respect others
my wishes
i know of a a young lady
a friend of mine who said when she told
she met this guy when she told the guy
you know all of this is off the table
until i say i do you put a ring on my
finger and all of this
and the man said to her
you know
i'm not used to this
but when i think about it i really
respect you for it
and he had to think about it for a while
he thought like a week and a half before
he called her back and when he called
her back it was to commend her
on the stance that she had taken
and and to
decide you know i need to get to know a
little bit more about your faith because
he was a christian but of a different
faith but i was just talking to her
so now he's looking into
her faith and trying to figure out what
makes her so different she's like i've
never met a woman like you before
you know so when when you take these
positions
god has a way of opening the eyes of
people to see
this person
is following
my law not just to the letter but in the
spirit of it which is what he asked her
to do
yeah my my daughter will be locked up
until she's at least 25 so you know
i mean that's i told my daughter i was
like phd that's right get your phd first
that's all i'm asking
what advice would you give a dating
couple the do's and the don'ts
okay so here's some advice
um this is what my dad told me it's like
you should never kiss a girl unless you
intend on marrying her that's good
advice i took that advice
only girl i ever kissed was my wife wow
that's awesome you have nothing to
compare to i don't know i think that is
the beauty of
of operating like god asks us
if you're dating you want to make sure
that most of the time you spend together
is also in the company of other people
so you don't want to be just the two of
you together all the time
things are going to get out of hand the
topics are going to change
do things in groups
you go places in groups you attend
functions in groups you go to your homes
different homes make sure that there are
always a lot of people and you're
observing the other person in the
situation
do
give her flowers
write her letters
man i know it doesn't it doesn't
seem like a big deal for guys like we're
like why come on and pick a flower and
give it to her like
girls appreciate that thing and and it's
just
and it does work both ways i noticed um
i never thought i cared about any of
that stuff i was just like i want to do
whatever makes my life happy and i never
felt like i needed anything like that
but i remember
my wife will do things like
when i go to the car in the morning
there's
like a
a snack or something like chocolate and
and a letter that just says i love you
and i'm like wow like my wife literally
took time she was thinking about me
while she was out and she got that thing
and she wrote that note and thought to
secretly put it in my car so that i
would see it it made me feel good i
guess i do as well when it gets serious
counseling oh yeah the other one uh
don't test
the other person like after
you know 9 10 p.m
you know because you know later on i
mean
you know testing or something late at
night just be by itself somewhere
or
uh don't send pictures
yeah you know nowadays
stuff you know don't send pictures you
know and
and um depends how old is a person you
know nowadays
you know 14 15 to have a little
boyfriend girlfriend whatever
but uh uh if you want to have a healthy
organic relationship
uh tell your parents you know
don't be
hitting
that relationship for the you know from
your parents so i guess they do is
uh
bring to the house yeah you know come to
know like hey this is the person you
know and the healthy relationship and
and like i said it's nice to have
boundaries
and you know just to have a good
healthy
relationship okay
i think don't date someone
if you feel like you have something
missing in your life
you are
handling another person's heart
for me some do's and don'ts of dating is
to consider that this is a person's
heart that is fragile and vulnerable and
the way i interact with them can be very
destructive or it can be very
positive and healing even if you don't
end up dating and i think i think having
some conversations in preparation for
how to navigate before you're in the
dates and i think that knowing that
someone is an individual of value
beyond the dating connection is huge and
i think that
um getting good advice from people who
have healthy relationships so that you
have a context when you go out for
dating so that you have kind of a
template for how to treat another person
and handle different scenarios and stuff
so that you don't unnecessarily bring
damage to people and they to you
well my one of my
advice gonna be
don't
um
don't make
don't easily make promises
i think
don't easily make promises to
the other one
the words you speak out
is very important yeah
my top dues in relationship is number
one to have boundaries
i think it is important i think one
thing that i haven't done enough is to
say no i'm not comfortable with that no
i don't want to do that
this is really important to me you know
and to stand on that i think it's
important to um
that both persons have a individual
relationship with god as well
i think too often we can kind of just
rely
too much on somebody else's faith in
where they're at and they pour into us
we don't know how to pour back into them
and i think that comes from having
individual relationships with god
my top don't is to number
yeah number one
probably just my only one is literally
to
not rush anything physical
do not awaken love before it's time like
even if it comes something as simple as
kissing i think
if you're gonna spend so much of your
time with somebody and that's going to
be part of the relationship why just
rush through that you know i think just
focus more on spending time with each
other and getting to know each other and
enjoying each other's presence because
this is not just the person you're going
to sleep with this is the person that
you're going to go grocery shopping with
and do all types of stuff together that
could be like you know just activities
family vacations all that so i think
that's super important and when you look
at the percentage of time you're going
to spend it's going to be a very
small uh percentage of time that's with
a physical and then a large percentage
of time that it's getting ready for work
and doing chores and taking care of kids
and all of that
so
we kind of have that in reverse don't we
what we value you know yeah
so the things that you you do is you do
things that will allow you to get to
know the other person
you do things that will enhance your
communication
you do things that you can grow
with together
as you do them you do things that will
build your spiritual relationship your
spiritual intimacy with god
we talked about knowing and
understanding yourself and i think when
it comes to dating
each person should know and understand
how they want to be treated
how they would like the other person to
to be
within reason
and also how to communicate those things
to that other person i think dating is
the is the best place to learn how to
cultivate that because it's not just you
communicating with them it's learning
how to communicate to them in the way
that they understand and vice versa
one way to find out is also to listen to
the words they use
if you're talking about something and
you make a point and someone says oh i
see i see
usually that person is visual
just look at all look at the words that
they use if they're using a lot of
visual type words they're usually visual
if you're talking to somebody and say
are you listening to me and they say i
hear you yeah i hear you
that person usually would be more
auditory now we we all have
all of those things in us but one is
usually predominant there are few of us
where they kind of equal so we just
interchange words and then if you are
explaining someone something to someone
and the person like man that grabbed me
so deeply that person is usually
kinesthetic so a lot of times we give
away the way we we actually
communicate best in the words that we we
use
does a minimum time come
to mind um dating period before marrying
someone some of the best advice that
someone ever gave me was
see the see your significant other
throughout all seasons
before you commit to marrying them and
that means a lot of different things not
only it doesn't mean you know spend a
full year of dating with them but it
also means see them through their
happiness see them through their sadness
see them if they have depression see the
see them if they are joyful and what
they're happy about all the seasons of
their personality there's an old saying
i think it's an indian saying of don't
marry somebody until you have summered
and wintered with them you've seen them
in their best and then you've seen them
in their worst because you get the then
you see the whole package deal you see
what you're getting yeah yeah
well i think for younger people
a year is fine
two years depending on how young you are
for older people i don't think there's
any time frame because by then you
should have figured out
how to
assess people
if you've done your inside work
six months
okay one year it's fine right but none
of this five-year thing if you're dating
someone if you're dating someone for two
years and you don't know that you want
to be that person or if you're a female
and the male has not proposed to you
keep walking
do not invest more than two years of
your time right anyway
if i break up with someone because i
feel like jesus told me to is that
biblical why do i still want them back
if you feel like you should
break up with someone
because god or your jesus told you to
you better pray about it and base that
on something that that is is hard and
fast and i even say from the bible
because you can have a desire to
continue and think that's from christ or
you can have a desire and think that
it's not for someone not not for you
because jesus is telling you that but it
might not be jesus telling you that it
might be your own heart
okay when i look at this person
the characteristics the mannerisms the
things that they want me to do
those things are not in line with god
said how god says i should
behave in the bible then yes jesus told
you to do so
but sometimes
there are some of us
who don't want to do certain things and
then we'll say you know jesus told me i
shouldn't do that
or the holy spirit says i shouldn't do
that when in in essence it's
we didn't want to do something
or we didn't want to come up front and
actually
communicate on a deeper level about the
thing
so if you're just hiding behind the
phrase jesus told me to do so then
that's not that's not a that's not
biblical i think we need to be careful
when we say jesus told me to because
sometimes that can also be toxic for
someone else to hear and can hinder them
in their relationship
they're like jesus doesn't like me he
told that girl to break up with me
exactly and that was something that i
like that was a i had to deal with that
afterwards and i felt so bad i didn't
know what to do
um and so i think that it's important
just be like you know what this just
isn't working out and we just don't fit
together you know or i need to focus
more on my spiritual life or something
like that but
um i think it is a valid reason because
if god tells us to do something it's for
our good and especially if we're feeling
the effects of that we should let it go
there's probably some principles here
that need to be thought about
and people like to phrase their
questions this way a lot so then this is
not a reflection on anybody so
i just noticed just generally we like to
use the word
feel
instead of the word think
and
god really wants us to
think our way through situations
not necessarily feel our way through
situations feelings are unstable
they are
will take us in all manner of directions
what we need to be able to do is reason
through the situation that
the the thoughts should
control
the feelings so feeling subject to
thoughts that's that's really the
hierarchy of things not the other way
around
that's tough um
interesting though i've never heard it
phrased that way that god told me to
break up with you i've heard a bunch of
god told me that you're the one for me
like let's get together and my response
is always if he's going to go ahead and
tell you he's going to tell me too
and i'm remembering like um joseph and
mary you know the angel came down and he
had a conversation with mary and he
definitely flew over to joseph before he
went back to heaven like there was
communication for both of them and also
with manoa manoa samson's parents
samson's mother was in the field doing
whatever work she was doing when the
angel prepared to her first she went
home and she told me no and manoa prayed
i was like okay lord who which whoever
it is that spoke to my send that person
to speak to me and the angel went and
spoke to him too that's right so god is
not going to speak to one person without
telling the other person but it may not
work the other way around that's what
i'm saying because depending on people's
connection to christ some people might
be living in in sin and their guilty
conscious has been removed like they're
not hearing the voice of god but if
you're in that kind of situation and god
is actually oppressing and pressing upon
your heart that hey this is not this is
not right there are ways to make sure
that it's the voice of god and not the
voice of satan or even your own
reservations and there's three three
common ways so just in general to know
whether your thoughts are of god he can
tell you through principles in his word
like as you're reading this is this is
the kind of person i want for you and
you're looking at the person that you're
with you're saying this doesn't add up
you know
god can i believe speak to you directly
he did that in my case you know he spoke
to my mind and said these very specific
words and i knew
then the third one is mentors people who
love and care for you the conversations
that you have is another way to confirm
whether what you're thinking is true
pray and ask god lord especially when
you're talking to people your parents
whatnot please speak to that person go
and ask them um
what do you think of my partner do you
think that we're a good fit just ask for
for counsel and be ready for what the
person tells you
and of course make sure that to um
take what the person is telling you and
of course back it up with scripture make
sure that they're sound in what they're
saying but
i mean i'm thinking of gideon you know
he he heard he saw an angel came and
visited him but he was like you know
what
let me let me double check let me triple
check and he put out his fleece and the
fleece fleece can look different for
different people um but the point is to
god is is willing to answer um
yeah this is one of the biggest
decisions in life go ahead and ask god
multiple times and ask for that
confirmation and when you get the answer
go through with it you know if it is to
walk away walk away
yeah just because when he closes one
door he opens another door or a window
and he opens the window jump through it
that's right
why you would want that person back well
because emotions are very strong and
you've
you've done things together that are you
know binding giving you butterflies and
this euphoria feeling
that's addictive like these chemicals in
your brain that get released
endorphins and
all these things
those are an addictive feeling you want
to feel that way and when that one
person makes you feel that way
it's almost like being
blinded like you feel like
oh it's only this one person in the
world that can make me feel like that
but that's not true you know god can
give you
believe me if this person
makes you feel that way and that's not
the one god has for you then the one he
has for you is going to be awesome and
perfect
i believe that
um and to answer why do i still want
them back because you made a connection
with that person like it's not like you
just if god tells you don't like to let
something go it's not like we don't have
an emotional attachment to it or that
it's just like a light switch and we can
turn our feelings off because i
struggled with going back and forth and
it just caused more damage like i think
the best thing to do is like if god till
you do something just
just like hold his hand through the
process and don't try to
like
you know go back to something that he
clearly said
is not for you
so yeah it ends up hurting both persons
thank you mama we got through it boom
well we hope you guys were edified by
today's love topics these were really
good questions there was a lot of
questions there what do you guys think
about this i mean put some questions in
the in the comments below and and engage
with us a little bit and tell us what
you kind of thought about the way that
we answered some of those and maybe if
you have some thoughts um of your own we
would love to hear them and love to
share them yeah we could do it again
thanks for the questions guys and please
continue to send more questions to us
and thank you so much for your love and
support without you guys we cannot do
this show we thank you so much for your
prayers and if you want to financially
support this ministry you can go to
patreon.com or you can even donate
through our website which actually helps
us even more that's lls.tv
donate don't forget to support and
social media and facebook instagram and
all the platforms thanks so much thanks
guys bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you